it's a rare condition when i say the
phrase iconic tv dad how does that make
you feel that we're honoring you with
this old
i don't have any kids of my own oh and i
had to get used to being a father as you
never would have known never would have
known oh i missed you so much today
daddy oh i missed you too the tgif
classic first premiered in 1989 and went
on to air nine seasons but audiences
were first introduced to carl and
harriet winslow played by joe marie
payton in perfect strangers hey baby ah
sweethearts
hi balcony
it was one episode that i had to go do
and we kind of connected she's wonderful
to work with they decided to put this
these two together and have her own show
and i was her husband and action
forget the eggs
we never had an argument or anything on
the set never never not once not ever
the same can't be said of joe marie and
jaleel white who played steve urkel you
better check that attitude at the door
he didn't have the etiquette that maybe
i and some others had there was one time
he actually wanted to physically fight
me i was gonna go down whip his behind i
was gonna whip his behind joe marie did
tell us during her interview that she
didn't have the greatest relationship
with jaleel during that time working
with him was a challenge there were some
moments when he was a little difficult
but um overall
i have nothing but good memories for him
got any cheese
so while family matters was jaleel's
breakout role reginald's was in 1988
playing a different sort of cop i'm kind
of busy right now i'll talk to you later
uh what's wrong with you you were cast
as sergeant al pal yes in die hard yes
would you call that your breakthrough
role yes of course
i didn't realize it at that time
a behind-the-scenes secret reginald
wasn't the first casting choice the
actor that had that road the role that i
played was supposed to be
you can say it that can i say it you can
say it was supposed to be gene hackman
really yes it was but uh something
happened and he didn't do it and they
decided to cast an unknown actor it was
the last day of uh of the casting when
it came into the room it was uh wesley
stipes and i said wes hey school you
know so he said well i said well you go
first so he went first and i i listened
at the door to him auditioning i never
told him that i love that now you know
wesley i did that so bruce willis he
said uh well let's get that guy and he
pointed me out and that's how i got the
role but you know ah no one knows that
you got yourself a good man
you take good care of him sadly bruce
recently announced his retirement from
acting due to the degenerative brain
disease aphasia we know that bruce is
dealing with
a health crisis right now and so any
just words of encouragement or love or
support to him he's the best actor to
work with and i appreciate what he gave
me and what he did in the film and i
wish him nothing but the best
[Music]